As the 2020 elections loom, the education
debates will be shaped by opinions that
get less attention than they deserve.
First: While most Americans give their
own community's schools an A or a B, just
a quarter give the nation's schools those grades.
That's why voters tune out candidates
who suggest their local schools are
failing, even while accepting that
schools somewhere else may need stronger
medicine. Second: three-quarters of Americans
support teacher pay increases,
but support drops substantially after
respondents are told what the average
teacher actually earns. Teacher pay
increases have real appeal, but teachers
should take care not to overstate their case.
Third: Americans — regardless of race — support
stricter school discipline by nearly
a ten to one margin. Parents will be
skeptical of proposals thought to weaken
school discipline. Candidates should take
care to listen to what voters think and
not just what advocates might have them believe.
Do you think teachers deserve a raise?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe more research
and videos from AEI.